[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique elle a une ce soir Cyril Rama
posa serein à l'ouverture du congrès de
l'ANC le président sud-africain c'est
qu'il est le grand favori pour prendre
la tête du parti au pouvoir et ce
maintenir à son poste au prochain
élections en 2024 malgré le scandale
plutôt que politique au judiciaire une
procédure de destitution nous irons sur
place dès le début de ce journal
lui aussi sera candidat à la prochaine
élection présidentielle en décembre 2023
en République démocratique du Congo et
il en a fait l'annonce sur France 24
Moïse Katumbi ancien gouverneur du
Katanga sort de sa réserve vous
l'entendez
et ce soir nous recevons une fois n'est
pas coutume une fée culturelle qui
disperse sa magie sur le continent
africain depuis plusieurs années la
Sénégalaise Aïcha dem et notre invité
elle publie un très beau livre dédié à
la créativité artistique de la capitale
sénégalaise Dakar ni d'artiste
on ouvre ce journal avec le sourire
crispé du président Cyril ramaosa au
congrès de la NC le président
sud-africain c'est qu'il est grand
favori au poste de prochain leader du
parti au pouvoir et ainsi futur chef de
l'État ceci malgré le scandale de
corruption qui l'entoure les
explications de notre correspondant en
Afrique du Sud Caroline Dumay
c'était une conférence pas tout à fait
comme les autres car pour la première
fois les divisions entre factions se
sont affichées officiellement partisans
de l'actuel président Cyril Rama pausa
contre partisan de l'ancien président
Jacob Zuma à l'extérieur de la
conférence les rebelles comme on les
appelle ont annoncé la couleur
ça passe ou ça casse
délégué de branche
[Applaudissements]
il va débattre
[Musique]
et à l'intérieur de l'hémicycle les
partisans de l'ancien président Jacob
Zuma non pas cessé de chahuter le
président Cyril Rama posa qui délivrait
son discours son bilan politique des
cinq ans de gouvernance et il continue
de condamner la corruption qui gangrène
les services publics
[Musique]
nous existons depuis 110 ans c'est
vraiment pas le moment d'afficher une
attitude aussi indisciplinée
si l'on en croit les nominations faites
au niveau des provinces le président
Cyril Rama posa est largement favori
avec plus de 2000 voix contre son rival
Solim kisez 900 voix mais on n'est pas à
l'abri des surprises les Sud-Africains
seront dimanche qui sera le prochain
président de la MC
d'une élection à une autre Moïse Katumbi
et candidat pour la prochaine
présidentielle en RDC le 20 décembre
2023 l'ancien gouverneur du Katanga en a
fait l'annonce sur notre antenne au
micro de Marc Perelman et de Christophe
Boisbouvier pour RFI on écoute comme la
situation continue à être chaotique je
dois sauver un peuple en danger
et je serai candidat en 2023 mais je
dois avaliser ma candidature au congrès
de notre partie le 19
à Lubumbashi donc j'essaierai candidat
parce que je une vision pour mon pays et
j'ai des j'ai un bilan quand j'étais
gouverneur et j'ai de l'expertise aussi
on reste en RDC ou des jeunes
s'organisent en groupe de vigilance
sorte de milice pour défendre la ville
de Goma chef-lieu de la province du Nord
qui vous tous disent avoir répondu à
l'appel du président congolais Félicity
pour défendre la patrie dans le
territoire du retour ou les
affrontements entre les rebelles biom23
et les forces armées congolaises se
poursuivent en dépit du ccfe les
autorités appellent les jeunes à
s'enrouler dans l'armée nationale
reportage à Goma Aurélie bazarrakiba
Angoula et Justin kaboumba
c'est Coline de l'Est de la République
démocratique du Congo sont aujourd'hui
sous haute surveillance
d'un groupe de vigilance sous ses ordres
une vingtaine de volontaires qui se sont
jurés de stopper l'avancée du M23 un
groupe rebelle qui contrôle une large
partie du territoire de route Chourou
tout proche de Goma nous savons que
l'ennemi juste derrière cette colline
des jeunes sont aussi déployés dans
d'autres zones pour bloquer les deux
membres qui sont morts à bounangana et
ailleurs dans des offensives des ennemis
ils sont morts par patriotisme nous
travaillons sans aucune assistance mais
nous avons devoir de défendre notre pays
et c'est pour ça qu'on reste dans le
camp
pas autorisés à filmer leur campement ni
leur armement ils affirment que leur
position doit rester secrète
ce jour là tout se prépare à partir en
patrouille je taille une lance ce sont
des armes plus utilisées nos ancêtres
elles sont très efficaces les lances
nous servent à tendre des embuscades à
l'ennemi dans la brousse et à lui ravir
ses armes dans le Nord qui vous
impossible de connaître le nombre de
jeunes qui se sont engagés dans des
groupes de vigilance depuis la reprise
des combats ils disent avoir répondu à
l'appel du président Félix Tshisekedi a
soutenir et appuyé les forces armées
congolaises mais agoma l'armée assure ne
pas collaborer avec ses milices il est
inconcevable qu'on remette une arme à un
civile vous voulez répondre à l'appel du
commandant supra et services sous les
drapeaux la procédure elle est claire
vous allez en formation
vous allez avoir tous les prérequis pour
servir sous les drapeaux
selon l'armée au moins 2000 candidats
ont répondu à l'appel à s'enrôler dans
les forces armées congolaises dans le
Nord qui vous plus de 10000 recrues sont
actuellement en formation sur l'ensemble
du territoire
[Applaudissements]
allez on passe au reste de l'actualité
en Afrique en bref et en images au Mali
deux membres de la municipale la mission
de maintien de la paix de l'ONU ont
vient d'être abattu par un assaillant il
s'agit de deux officiers de police ils
étaient en train d'effectuer une
patrouille près de la ville de
Tombouctou
quatre autres pour l'instant aucune
information sur la saillant
l'ambassadeur du Ghana au Burkina Faso a
été convoqué suite aux propos du
président nana à kufo ADO selon lesquels
Ouagadougou avait conclu un arrangement
avec le groupe paramilitaire russe ou
Wagner ce que le pays ni tout en disant
vouloir réexéminer ses relations avec la
Russie la Russie encore mais en
Centrafrique Moscou affirmé que l'un de
ses représentants avait été blessés par
l'explosion d'un colis piégé une attaque
que le chef de groupe paramilitaire
russe Wagner a imputé à la France
accusation démentie par Paris
on termine par le Sénégal ou les deux
députés de l'opposition qui ont frappé
une collègue de la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale ont été écrouées
jeudi à Dakar et seront jugés lundi pour
coups et blessures volontaires
notre invité de ce soir est surnommé la
fée culturelle un titre affectueux
décerné par les artistes africains et
particulièrement se installer à Dakar
ville où elle exerce sa magie depuis
plusieurs années il était donc logique
qu'elle lui consacra un livre Dakar ni
d'artistes de la mode à la musique en
passant par les arts la littérature la
photographie ou le cinéma ce livre a
rassemblé les plus grands noms du
secteur culturel sénégalais eychadem
merci d'être dans ce journal de
l'Afrique merci d'être avec nous
merci de me recevoir Fatima alors Aïcha
dites-nous déjà pourquoi Dakar est
devenu ces dernières années cette plaque
culturelle exceptionnelle
la créativité
il y a une énorme créativité à Dakar et
les partout même dans la rue mais il y a
aussi un dynamisme dynamisme absolument
remarquable des jeunes surtout qui
aujourd'hui ils ont confiance ils sont
très créatifs mais ils ont confiance et
ils sont surtout très connectés Fatima
ils sont très connectés avec internet
c'est des enfants d'Internet donc il n'y
a plus de limites on les voit le monde
des voies et n'oublions pas aussi que
Dakar et aussi le Sénégal et un pays qui
a su imposer des événements phares dans
le monde comme la Biennale
oui bien sûr alors ce très bel ouvrage
c'est un très bel objet et très bien
écrit et c'est pas un recueil je sais
que vous ne vouliez pas en faire un
recueil de notice biographique sous le
style de Wikipédia mais une vraie
collection de regards intimes des
artistes sur la ville et sur leurs
œuvres
on se promène avec donc je ne voulais
pas faire de Wikipédia des notes comme
ça sur il nous donne beaucoup de choses
qui sont très généreux il est important
pour moi de montrer leur travail de
montrer leur personnalité un peu de
montrer la puissance et la force de leur
a et de le faire aussi avec poésie
puisque c'est des trésors de beauté
absolument beaucoup de poésies tout au
long de ce livre alors il va falloir
vous mouiller Aïcha à présent du fait de
son cosmopolitisme le la ville de Dakar
aux gorges de talent venu partout dans
le monde mais vous qui êtes sénégalaise
est-ce que vous avez appris des choses
d'ailleurs sur cette ville grâce à ses
artistes
oui on apprend toujours
j'ai surtout eu beaucoup d'anecdotes
c'est ça qui est drôle des anecdotes
qui m'ont appris par exemple sur des
personnages que je ne connaissais pas
qui sont qui sont des personnages
incontournables et la façon dont ils
vivaient aussi beaucoup appris sur les
artistes c'est des choses que je savais
déjà mais on les écoutant en échangeant
beaucoup avec eux ça m'a ça a confirmé
ce que je savais de Dakar mais j'ai
beaucoup appris avec je ne pourrais pas
je ne pourrai pas on n'aura pas le temps
il nous faut une anecdote au moins
inch'Allah vous avez mis l'eau à la
bouche il nous faut au moins une
anecdote il faut attendre de lire les
livres Fatima mais je vous dis j'ai eu
des anecdotes assez incroyables avec
oasis Diop le chanteur absolument que
nous avons reçu ici d'ailleurs
puis qui est magnifique qui a pris de
personnages de Dakar qui du vieux Dakar
qui c'est pas ma génération donc des
personnages qui étaient là qui étaient
connus de tous mais qui était juste dans
le Dakar comme ça créatif que tu sais
absolument fabuleux c'est vraiment
magnifique et alors vous racontez
souvent d'ailleurs cette il y a un Dakar
évidemment ce qu'on appellerait Old
School mais voilà plus ancien avec cette
nouvelle génération comment justement ça
s'articule ça parce qu'on le voit dans
votre livre finalement qui a vous
arrivez à faire une sorte d'harmonie
parce que finalement ces artistes là
cohabitent et même finalement se
retrouve et se rejoignent pour faire des
œuvres communes
mais c'est ça qui est beau en fait dans
le Dakar culturel il y a plusieurs
générations il y a c'est très éclectique
mais c'est ça c'est les dynamisme dont
je parlais est vraiment ils font avec
peu il n'y a pas les moyens mais ce qui
est beau ce qui a beaucoup de
collaboration sur ton corps il faut
auprès des jeunes par exemple une
célérabicane avec des family ce genre de
choses ils sont souvent collectifs et la
créativité augmente encore plus quand
ils sont ensemble et ils m'ont beaucoup
j'ai et c'est ça qui est beau et c'était
c'était important de montrer de montrer
cette palette là
des générations précédentes à maintenant
et de montrer aussi cette richesse cette
diversité ensemble c'était important
pour nous absolument merci beaucoup
Aïcha dem pour ce magnifique livre Dakar
ni d'artiste le livre sortira le 22
décembre et c'est évidemment un
formidable cadeau que je recommande
vivement à tous merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis c'est ainsi qu'on
referme ce journal de l'Afrique alors de
Dakar à Johan en passant par Niamey
rester avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur France 24
[Musique]
moi j'avais vu un film en fait on voyait
des femmes très formées etc avec un
corps parfait moi en fait